okay so we're a little closer now
because we dare not disturb Naruto I'd
rather somebody said we shouldn't do
SteriPEN I was all fine with just
sitting on him but somebody was like no
don't do that because he's a living
being and we don't want him to die we
really have to be more worried about
your friends
yeah that's Jeff Eli go animal cruelty I
am a captain I was very insulted when
you said okay this is guardians of
sunshine and I really like this one cuz
this is one where they go into a video
game world and they get all sort of 3d
pixelated and a very Minecraft it looks
like to me and they go in and they that
they go they go into fimo pretty much
whoo and now that you mentioned is the
voice of a little Rainicorn of the
Rainicorn now it's like I can't not hear
if I was actually shocked when they said
he I was just like oh I wasn't even sure
BMO what psyche so Oh again it's up in
the air they call me he the coal machine
I didn't really call the same females
are shooting something yeah it's BMO
okay just you need sex oh yeah is that
actually how the name is spelt do it's
just the letter B and then M oh yes okay
and they go out of which what I do like
about this is that it does sort of I
think anyone that's played video game
has said this and I'm sure we said to
it's like if I was there in real life
this would be a lot easier this game is
what's wrong and it's like yeah jumping
over a pit of lava and stuff like really
easy and fighting something with a sword
yeah real easy stuff I know my physical
limitations I would know I'd not be able
to jump over a pit or slay a dragon or
even win in a street fight or run a run
in track and field so no I've never
actually thought that effort I think
it's more like you know like a glitch in
a game where it's like all you to do is
like get close the edge and just do like
a low jump or walk across but there's
like uncle H or something
that's not usual we talking about we
talk about the stuff like you say like
if I was really there it's like no we'd
be dead I totally take on like 20 people
I'd be fighting in Tekken and man I'd
kick all their um so yeah so I like
kind of the effects of this why I like
sort of the 3-d idea i love all the
little i get all the little touches that
this show does i love it there's one
part where they're singing about being
in the video game and Finn's face with
his mouth turns into a little pong like
his eyes are the paddles that his mouth
becomes the ball and it's like that was
hilarious it's just a little thing to
the side and this show is just filled
with little touches like that and every
time we start talking about this - in
between well look at that story there's
at least like six or seven people that
work on the story is it just something
where they put on their hey we also work
on this season in general so we also
work on stories or just get little
tidbits here and there is something or
is it literally like they all come
together on one episode do it and go to
the next episode like all equally or
whatever do you know as far as I can
tell and no I don't know facts don't
yell at me and say I'm wrong because I'm
not saying I know exactly but no it
seems that it's pretty much the same
group the entire time it's kind of like
a safeguard like yeah while we were
talking about the season and we'll just
put everyone's name on there because you
came up with this kind of idea which we
didn't necessarily use in that episode
but we used it tennis later yeah I so
see in the cast - like they'll be one
like you know Princess Bubblegum was
voice 5x but like she wasn't in the
episode but she might be in the next one
yeah there's something like that so yeah
I think it's just sort of a general you
know big safety net everybody in um but
yeah and when they get to the end like
they they get outside they get out of
BMO and then the creatures follow um
bumping in the sunlight so it's okay
because they just want the sunlight but
then they want to kill people and that
was bad so they I'm forgetting oh that's
why they did the move the little left
left up down quick again I mean anyone
that no it was like the old left right
be a slick skirt that's got to player
yeah
I mean that's those moves are just like
still sort of ingrained like there's so
many people I can't remember things that
are vital to like survive half the time
it's like they'll still remember up-down
left-right you know all those codes and
I like this episode because those sound
effects and those mana fixes that are
still like freaking heaven to me I just
hear those sounds and they just sound so
good it's like I wish I could be like oh
it's just understand your thing well it
is just a nostalgic thing but by god I
love them so much I mean whenever even
that opening screen uh which was very
Pixley had the little press start and
stuff it's like I love seeing that just
yeah those things so uh this was right
up my alley I thought was really cool
what I love is like the entire time
we've been doing this you've been
talking about how it's very video gaming
and I'm like oh god I can't wait till he
sees this one where it is a video game
pretty much
I thought you get a kick out of that but
I like personally with as you're seeing
the small things the sound effects
because I'm so used to nowadays hearing
like the sound effect when someone gets
something it's the sonic getting the
ring or Mario getting the coin yeah in
this one it's like all pretty much Atari
or ColecoVision or in television sound
effects yeah they're very especially
there's one point I think it like the
game overs I sound like oh like this
really really low beat and it's like
anime that's why I like to even more cuz
I serve bringing up these memories it's
like I'm I totally forgot about these
sounds you know it's like I love your
enemy game though some of them were
biting me of berserk and yeah like
that's what I like is it's not the new
game sound or the okay we'll say the
mid-ground sounds it's the old
old-school once and that's what I used
to play so against first god sound but
yeah I mean there is certain more of
like a nostalgia for that because it is
like I mean Atari for me it was like the
first system I ever played pretty much
and so yeah hearing those sounds it is
just like it Oh Baroness taja I know it
is but
I love it I just think it's great you
know so yeah trying to think done not
too much else I mean it's it's good I
like the layout of the of the world and
make it all green and how they're
pixelated and stuff like that and look
at my arm
or who look at me yeah like man yeah the
zeros and ones and stuff was really
clever and I like how I like how Jake
can sort of you know pixelate himself at
different versions and sort of whenever
he moves it's very you knowing blocks
and stuff so no I did I know I thought
was really funny and really clever I
like when Jake jumped off and he comes
back it is like great I had another life
and all that and he's like okay we've
got to be very careful and takes just
like did to do jumps off the galley good
see these just like we he wasn't even
trying to make it a crowd these jumps in
and then he's dying is like I'm burning
I'm burning and he comes back he's like
hey this is also what I also really
enjoyed his when finish a tour when
finished playing the game initially on
BMO and he gets eaten by the Frog and he
gets it pooped out and this little like
little disc yeah gone out and then he
actually gets eaten in the game and he
gets pooped out himself and I'm like wow
frogs pooping don't see that very often
pixelated frogs but yes so poor BMO and
Bob BMO Finn definitely did not learn
his lesson this time around yeah okay
that was the one thing at this hour man
to if once BMO does the little move what
was gonna happen to them well doesn't
get thrown back into the game or oh he's
trying to kill him and wow that's pretty
harsh for BMO Oh Oh what did they do to
him they literally violated the play of
God okay true there was like rape I
don't like in an epic scale yes and also
you know real physical abuse cuz yeah
like this big gaping hole on the side
that's like you know but you have ahead
of coming yeah yeah poor little BMO I
hope they don't come back
down left right
oh hi how're you good I'm okay thanks
how's jewelry
sleeping as usual police know she's not
snoring my way where I called it Naruto
so that won't work it's a cat
what do you so cat that can be flattered
I'll take care of that see you next time